John Perry here it is Wednesday the
moment you've all been waiting for I'm
about to reveal what this mystery
creature from last week was right here
right now on what's it Wednesday this a
lot of you thought was a rodent of some
sort this is not a rodent some of you
thought it was a rat it's not a rat this
is a lagomorph this is a cottontail
rabbit
between rodents and lagomorpha is that
lagomorph have four incisors on the top
which we which we saw last time and
lagomorph s-- have enamel on both the
front in the back of their teeth so it's
actually harder for them to grind their
teeth down into the chisel shape that
we're seeing here lagomorph sand rodents
both have continually growing teeth so
they're constantly grinding their teeth
down and sharpening them on their food
and the same is true before their molars
their molars are constantly growing and
if you look at the the way that the the
jaw hinge works it actually enables some
sliding forward and back quite a bit
quite a bit of sliding which is good to
help them sharpen those teeth and you
know make sure they're there all things
are in order
there are some major benefits and having
teeth that grow continually obviously
you can you know wear them down and your
it's cool it's okay you know beavers the
most obvious example of having a huge
benefit because they can constantly grow
their teeth but being able to constantly
grow your teeth also has its
disadvantages if there is any sort of
jaw injury that makes it so that you
cannot grind your teeth down you are
pretty much screwed let me show you this
picture this is my book on skulls it's
pretty cool
little book here
that it shows this horrible horrible
example of a if a rabbit that for some
reason was not able to grind his teeth
down and they just curl in and cause
horrible pain for the animal this guy
probably starved to death wasn't able to
eat because his teeth got a little
messed up so you know there are pros and
cons to many things in evolution
horrible way to go yeah so cottontail
rabbit congratulations to all you who
got that correct alright now for this
week's guest I have something very very
special to show you I'm really excited
about this guy please ignore the droopy
bone there that's held on with a piece
of tape
this came to me from Shenton mini
Wildlife Center as well just like the
rabbit skull
unfortunately I'm missing the jaw for
this critter but even though it's not in
perfect condition I'm also missing the
sclerotic rings that birds have they
have that little ring of bones in the
eye which this guy is missing but I feel
like this is still a really worthy guest
on our show because it shows a really
neat example of cranial Kinesis so in
humans and in most mammals were used to
all joints being like true joints where
two bones come together and so all of
the movement for the most part and our
body is between bones I mean there's a
little bit of flexing of bones it
happens when you walk you know bones
Bend a little bit but in birds they have
not all birds but in this species and
many others they have a really thin spot
of bone up here on the top
and they've got muscles that allow this
whole front part of the beak to move and
when this thing was alive this bone up
here was very oily and flexible it's now
dry and brittle so I have to be really
careful when I show you how this moves
but I will be able to show you a little
bit I'm just gonna gently pull
can you see that you can see that the
this entire bottom piece of bone here
slides forward and the beak turns upward
and that is not a true joint that's
actually the flexing of bone and these
birds do that in life let's look at that
from the bottom real close up here
see that movement this structure of bone
here just slides forward
this animal to have extremely dexterous
movement of the beak it can very
delicately
maneuver its food it can very delicately
groom its own feathers groom the
feathers of a loved one as Birds so
awesomely do birds can't reach the
feathers on the back of their neck so a
lot of times when they and they pair up
to mate their mate or even sometimes in
some species that are really social just
their buddies will groom the back of
their necks for them which is one of the
sweetest things in nature
I love seeing animals groom each other
there's even there's even examples of
cross species grooming where two birds
will get together from totally different
species and decide to groom each other's
feathers
it's freaking adorable cranial Kinesis
in this in this species which is not
doesn't happen in all birds what happens
in quite a few it's a really neat unique
joint birds have all kinds of weird
joints in their bodies that you wouldn't
expect very unusual compared to mammals
like ourselves these these little bones
here act as shades they they create a
structure that goes over the eye pokes
out a little bit over the eye kind of
like a baseball cap to shield from too
much sunlight so yeah really really neat
specimen let me know what you think this
is in the comments good luck stay
curious